in case you didn't know the words
plug-in don't only refer to doing this
but the one word option is actually a
handy extension for your internet
browser and now there's a great plug-in
to help you navigate through the world
of fake news it's called
news guard it won't ping up fake news
alerts like the anti-virus software when
you click on a story link for now news
guard provides descriptions for news
sources not individual articles or
stories right here you can see what it
looks like are green red ratings signal
if a website's is trying to get it right
or instead has a hidden agenda or
knowingly publishes falsehoods or
propaganda
so there's a whole rating system with as
many as nine criteria stuff like the
responsibility of journalists or telling
apart news from opinion to name a couple
so who are the champions and being as
green as you can get the New York Times
or The Washington Post with a perfect
record for all nine categories despite
having been caught for publishing lies
and it wasn't a one-off news guard will
tell you they're nowhere near being
repeat offenders now someone would
definitely call that fake news so
technically what makes the alert switch
from green to red or vice versa we use
humans not algorithms to identify
unreliable news because we believe our
work should be done with transparency
and accountability I knew it it's up to
human beings paid on job oops
one of news guards biggest investors
formerly of the Wall Street Journal was
blamed for turning out fakes the news
guard advisory board is also worth
having a look at it features esteemed
men like the former director of the CIA
and NSA the first Secretary of Homeland
Security and the Bush administration
Barrack Obama's former Undersecretary of
State for public diplomacy by the way
Richard Stengel once said
I'm not against propaganda every country
does it and they have to do it to their
own population and I don't necessarily
think it's that awful and what
these folks running the show it's pretty
easy to guess if RT falls into the red
or green territory so go download that
plug-in ASAP and always be cautious when
you read RT or anything else news guards
turned tomato red eyes just for fun
downloaded the app in preparation for
this interview and I looked at LA Times
comm which is the website of the Los
Angeles Times which gets a green rating
which means that the website is
considered trustworthy and prints
usually prints true and verifiable
information now I'm personally suing the
Los Angeles Times right now for
defamation and libel because they
printed lies about me so I know that the
rating is not a hundred percent reliable
for first hand so that was my that was
my test the leadership of the news guard
is unfortunately people who have kind of
a fraught relationship with the truth in
the past and who have way too many ties
to the establishment and in particularly
to be what we would call the deep state
here in the United States to see former
CIA and NSA people I would say are
pretty much like the last people you
would want to see create this kind of
app
you